and we are live welcome everybody
another YouTube hang out third one of
the day super excited to be on with a
student entrepreneurs ieave who I met at
a startup event here in Toronto I was at
a meeting with the mayor on a panel kind
of helping figure out what Toronto could
do to encourage more startups and and we
met and he wrote to me to say hey Kim
can we connect again I have some
questions and I said let's turn it into
a YouTube hang out so we can inspire
other student entrepreneurs as well this
is his very first time on a YouTube
hangout so let's be nice and welcome
aboard safe thanks thanks for having me
Evan pleasure to be here so you've got
you got me for half an hour let's do it
what questions you have how can I help
yeah yeah sure um I guess I'll just do
the one minute little intro to my
business again so i'm working on a
platform called night foodie where i
help connect consumers to timely
discount food deals anytime anywhere and
the whole goal is to help reduce surplus
food waste by getting consumers to the
perishable foods same day same day foods
and we're working on the platform
through the application through an app
so there's two apps one on consumer side
one of the partners item we try to help
connect them that's the that's the angle
i guess a couple my questions really
stem from business development and from
hearing about your story you worked at a
biotech startup and you helped grow that
in the business side so we're still
pretty early stages i just landed my
first two partners officially like last
week so that was pretty exciting and i
want you to know how to I guess expand
more and faster with like as a little
manpower as I have right now so who the
two partners that you brought on so I
prod brought on one sushi place and the
other one is sushi / during such a sort
assortment of stuff so one of them is
called mocking my way and the other ones
broking they're both situated downtown
Toronto so what I would do is over when
you are first setting up you got to be
able to provide value to your customers
and so yeah it happens so many times you
come up with a business model and say
this is how I'm gonna make money is how
I'm going to provide value and then it
and then it changes because your
assumptions are wrong you didn't have
the right idea you know I changed my
business too and I missed a huge
opportunity because we didn't pivot
passin up to it so what I would be doing
is those start with those to really get
an understanding of their business
problems and how you can help solve them
right branch out from there to look at
is this something that you can offer on
a geographic area so if you're doing
downtown does it help you to be able to
connect with all the other downtown
places right within three blocks of both
of those sushi restaurants there's got
to be tons of other restaurants you can
connect to introduce yourself to but you
have to have a strong value prop to be
able to know their problems and address
them through your service it's
interesting that both our sushi so the
other option is to not just go
Geographic but also targeted towards an
industry so can you be the guy for the
sushi business and then spread out
across the city and then eventually go
national global uh you know so are there
other specific problems of the sushi
restaurant business that you saw that
doesn't apply as well to a bagel shop to
a diner or you know can to be everything
can you help everybody right so that
comes from really understanding the two
businesses that you already have as
clients before worrying about going
crazy expansion and providing massive
value to those two clients so they love
you and can't imagine their business now
without you one of the one of the things
with the the platform working on right
now is it's still in development so it's
not fully out yet a lot of the times I'm
trying to sell the cell the partners on
the idea and sure showcasing them the
beta that we have right now um so I
liked how you said you're supposed to
target the different you should be
focusing on like the different types of
stores and food stores and rightfully so
like we've been trying to target more
bakeries sushi places bagel shops
because they make a lot
more sense for the surplus food and
currently what we've been trying to do
is a little different because again the
product wasn't fully developed and
finished yet so we're trying to do right
now is just to populate the app with a
bunch of discount food deals that
already exist at a bunch of places so
for example I'm mocking my way they have
like from three to six certain certain
percentage off certain prices sorry
certain percentage of certain items and
what we did was we took some of those
deals and we just put it right in the
platform just a way to grow a little bit
of the user base and partners and then I
plan on telling them about the whole
surplus side even though I did initially
mention it to them but for now we're
that's sort of what we're doing even
though it were not targeting the surplus
food right away that should inherently
still reduce surplus food I just one of
your thoughts on that so we're a little
different than what we're aiming to do
right now yeah so you want to make sure
that you want to make sure that your
offer is related to the service that you
want to eventually really add value on
right otherwise it may mean like that
you're spending time with the wrong
customers so these sushi guys may say
yes great we have these sales from three
to five happy hour whatever lifts those
but we don't have any surplus food
problems that we don't we don't have
time to deal with that or send a big
problem for us where you've invested all
this time when your relationship with
trying to build that up and you're going
down a path of solving one problem for
them which is just exposure but not the
one that you want to try to solve for
them right so that becomes a challenge
if you're opening up the door but it may
not be the right door and that may not
lead to the place that you want to go
the side part of that is like how
committed are you to this food surplus
idea because by opening up these doors
to the retailer's it may lead to other
opportunities that you didn't even think
about but by talking to them it leads to
business now you gotta still be passion
about that business not just jump on an
opportunity but I think of wrigley if
you look at remember Wrigley's the gum
right they can start of office as
get what it was I think they started off
as like a baking soda company and then
they started giving soap away as a free
bonus and then the soap became so
popular they started becoming a soap
company like a forget baking soda we're
going to do so so Brett learns that and
he had soap and they gave away gum as a
bonus by five things a soap would give
you gum people love the gum so much they
said if you forget so we're going to
sell gum and then gum became the thing
that they took off with so we're said
they were giving away in providing
unrelated products and eventually one
hit and that became their business so I
guess it depends on what your vision is
because if you want to be in the surplus
food business and solving that problem
because you know wasted food is a
passion of yours and you don't want to
see food wasted anymore you know
whatever your story is behind that then
this would not be the best way in
because you don't know that these guys
would even care about that service from
where it's better the target restaurants
who are open conversation like yeah this
is a problem for us and maybe you don't
have the answer yet you know but you
have a discussion somebody's willing to
sit down and talk to you about it if
your goal is just I want to get to know
restaurants and see what kind of
business I can make for them this is an
easy way in so I'm just constant of you
spending your time on a wrong thing and
it has to align with what your ultimate
vision is so it's not necessarily wrong
just depends on which way you want to go
okay it's interesting yeah yeah I'm
gonna have to give that another thought
because some a lot of sort of the
opportunity that I'm chasing right now
it's it's it's an idea that just came to
me and it's a problem I face personally
I wouldn't say this was the one hundred
percent passion that I've always had
about food waste know what not but it
did it was a problem and then when I
started talking to other people it's
like yeah we we do this and this happens
and so I I got some approval on that
sort of sense and validation so that's
our the basis for it but I'm definitely
open to pivoting the idea if need be but
i'll keep I'll keep that in mind when
I'm trying to target target the right
people for the for the right product and
when you
pivoting it should be to something that
you have passion for not just because
you see an opportunity in so if you you
know so okay so here you know I have
these canvases on my wall if you're in
the canvas the printing campus business
and you believe people need to have a
great environment to work in and that
inspires them you might want to talk to
youtubers who are broadcasting shows
with stuff and make their background
more you know interesting inspiring
motivation or whatever if you come to me
as youtuber and say hey Evan I'd like to
talk about this new plan I have to help
promote your channel through advertising
or whatever great i might be interested
because i want to promote my channel but
it doesn't mean that i have an interest
in your canvases right so you can keep
talk to me about this and we may start a
relationship around this thing which
you're not making any money off of
you're just trying to build a
relationship but it's not to like I'm
never going to buy from you I'm not
interested I already have my camera says
I don't want anymore you never even
asked me if I was you know curious about
it and so is there a different model
they can then sell those youtubers on
something else sure but is that what
you're passionate about becomes
important okay uh yeah I guess I'll move
on to my second little question um I was
thinking about so when I was dabbling in
the space in this or like my very first
startup doing all this is asking a lot
of people for opinions advice some from
people just like yourself and could you
speak a little about about understanding
what is the right advice to take because
it sometimes it can be confusing because
a lot of people give do this do that or
this work really well for me and
sometimes I can get in my own little
head space sure you know first
understand with any advice it's it's
it's those people seen the world through
their eyes right so they have
experiences and contacts that may not be
relevant to you and so you need to take
everything with a grain of salt and a
good mentor will will not just be
absolute like it won't be this is the
only way to do it
this is what worked for me so I listened
to advice one I would say for me it's I
want to first figure out what I'm super
passionate about like I would rather I
think if you are going up to people and
saying hey I'm thinking about a business
which business you think i should start
I think that's the wrong approach
because I think you can make a business
out of anything when you are super
passionate about it this is about
providing value you can provide value to
somebody you'll make money and the
easiest way to provide value is if you
have a passion a love of what you're
doing and of helping a customer so
that's just coming back to the point of
view if you love the idea of solving the
surplus food waste thing you know if you
know you saw on TV people who are
struggling and can't survive and aren't
eating and you hate the idea that people
around the world don't have food and
here we are with all the surplus food
and you want you know like if that's
like that's your core mission like
that's what means helping to you then
then then you may be going down the
wrong path that just mean these
restaurants and hasn't let the sales so
I think it's better to say if it were me
it'd be better to say I have a passion
for this these are some of my interest
how do I turn this into a business
opportunity because what I may think
it's a business like I see business
opportunities everywhere right but you
may not be interested in it so for me to
tell you hey listen that's the wrong
idea go do this you can just open up the
list of the ink magazine top 100 hottest
businesses to start and just go do that
but if you don't have a passion for any
of those you won't be successful so just
because something is taken off and is
hot doesn't mean you have a business so
I would be looking at trying to have
some self-awareness to figure out what
you love and then ask people hey how do
you think I can make a business off of
this right and it's then start
brainstorming they're the best people to
talk to our people who've already done
what you are trying to do it can give
you some insight a lot of people you
know first reaction you go talk to their
parents they go talk to their friends
the fact that people were currently
around them and they may get a lot of
hate they may get like
if you tell your parents hate mom and
dad I want to start this business they
may say that's crazy go and get a safe
job and be an accountant or a doctor or
lawyer or whatever and I'm just using an
example I'm sure your parents you know
are amazing people but understand what
it's all out of love like even if your
parents or friends don't support the
ideas because they're scared because
they see the world through their eyes
and they would never do it and so they
see it as being too risky for you to go
out and do and so if somebody has done
what you want to do then you can their
advice becomes more meaningful if your
parents or friends have never done what
you are trying to do then their advice
doesn't really help you write like my
parents taught me how to be a human
being to care about others how to treat
people how to value people how to be
nice to people you know relationships so
I listened to them on that right ah
business advice they don't they never
never started a business they're not
entrepreneurs they do other stuff and so
you know if I had a notch very real
question I wouldn't go to them i would
go to try to find other people and
respect their their feedback so um
whenever i'm talking to somebody if i
were you i'd be looking at how they've
done what i want to do and can you know
do I trust that wisdom because again a
lot of people are asking the wrong
people because it's convenient to ask
your friends and family but if they
haven't done it how is their opinion
valuable really you might want to do the
opposite because they haven't done what
you want to do so why are you guys to
get there and then the last little bit
about that on taking advices I've almost
never been able to take someone's advice
word for word and apply it I've had to
tweak it to make it my own so I remember
going through since you know the YouTube
channel I did a lot of media training
with my agent and every week I had a
media call with a call with one of my
media coaches to train me on how to get
better on doing YouTube interviews all
that stuff and every week she gave me
exercises to work on and the exercise is
never quite hit it was always like her
ideas are always great but there was
always just not quite for me and I had
to try it and be awkward at it and not
enjoy it and then find the tweak to make
it my own so like you can't just copy
everything Steve Jobs did or Howard
shola Terry piccinini or any of those
guys but you could learn from them take
what work for them and say how can I
apply this to my business and put my own
little sigh you for you know twist on it
yeah be successful because it's rarely
just copy and paste you got to add a
little bit to it too hmm now I
definitely agree with you because it's
it's hard to do a business where you
don't see the value where it doesn't
quite a line with your interests or
passions I mean for example in this
startup this tired I'm working on right
now um the idea and how it came about
was over the course of a couple months
weeks years just planning on by so when
I was going to all these restaurants I'd
see at the end the night that they were
just throwing away all this food and you
know you'd see the homeless guy on the
other side of things um and then there
is that huge disconnect so I started
googling obviously just trying to figure
things out what existed what didn't and
and I knew this this seemed like a
really familiar new space to be in even
though they're there was some growth and
currently right now after the two or
three months that I've been working on
this they're there do seem to be like a
lot of competition coming in and trying
to really expand here so the the
business I started wasn't necessarily
just because I just saw the opportunity
but also that I felt felt like there's
something there yeah I think it's
against maybe typical business advice
that you read in the text book we're
looking at the competition I firmly
believe you could you could be
successful and have a business in any
industry if you have a deep passion for
what you're doing there will be other
people who share that passion and want
to do it or if all you do is look at the
competition it's never going to make
sense because there's always big
competition in every field right we just
did a profile of the GoPro founder
you know and when he started he wanted
to have video cameras at shot action and
he could have said well look you know
Sony is their cannon is there you know
nikon is there they're not quite doing
it yet but I could start and they could
crush me because there's some huge big
company with tons of money and I'm just
getting started and it did the safe like
logical textbook thing to do he wouldn't
have started the business mm-hm almost
no industry looks great on paper because
there are big competition and you are
your odds of success are tiny anywhere
what brings you through is the
passionate mean to made him a
billionaire taking on those big
companies and create a new category so
whatever it is like if I love water
bottles there's an advertiser whole
foods and I love water bottles right
like man water bottles are broken I want
to make new water bottles out of hemp or
whatever it is and I just have a serious
passion for water and hydration and just
all I could talk about was consuming
water I can have success in the water
bottle business even though it's super
competitive in price driven and
everybody's selling it right them so
that's the most important thing to
figure out is yours for yourself what do
you love what are you passionate about
and then how can I before you think
about business how can I take that
passion and help other people how can i
add value to their lives to their
businesses and at the end of the day
making a successful business is about
that providing value so if you can go
out and provide value to them and do it
consistently then you'll get paid to be
able to do it because at the start you
won't be good at it like you may not you
know with your app you don't have enough
customers coming in so you can't charge
for this yet right right yet it's fine
like I'm not it's not a criticism like
anybody like when you first started out
you don't have the skills you may have
the passion but you don't have the
skills yet you need to get better right
it's fine so whatever you do you're
going to start at Ground Zero and work
your way up but you can get there a lot
faster when you are passionate about it
because you could pass somebody I'd much
rather bring on the guy who is deeply
passionate to learn but hat knows
nothing then the guy who knows every
has no excitement like you will learn so
quickly think about like when you were
really excited to learn something how
quickly you picked it up versus being
forced to read chemistry textbooks and
memorize something like your second all
about it all the time is gone right hey
um so it's going to be like what are the
things to think about consistently and
then how can you use that to help other
people in some way that's the starting
of a good business okay yeah that's a
lot of deep thoughts I a I guess I'll
have to go back and reflect on a lot of
what you said um in terms of so going
back to your very first very first
company that you were working with could
you put take me through like your very
first sale of acquiring that customer
how was that process like uh super
nervous nerve-wracking uh I was selling
scientific software I was 19 years old I
didn't have a science background x was
my worst subject and here I was trying
to sell the guys you know to three times
my age with PhDs and tons of degrees and
I actually didn't sell anything in
person or by the phone at the start
because I was too nervous I thought
they're not gonna take me seriously you
know I was afraid of rejection so I
thought I'm just going to sell my email
because they don't know how old I am
right and I won't get caught up with a
question I don't know how to answer yeah
you know so email is always easier uh
I'm not actually held me back to help me
back and it was until I realized that
these guys for the most part don't care
how old I am all they care was that I
can help them you know they were running
research labs and our software could
help the research lab do things better
and if I could show that to them they
would they would care they would listen
to me I think it's never been easier for
young people to get respect and to get
it sales because the older generations
realize that they don't have the
knowledge like it used to be experienced
always trump that you did the same thing
always in an industry now the indices
are change
you so quickly that the young people
will have more knowledge about a certain
way things are done like social media
like website development like you know
there aren't that many 65 year old
website development experts right right
like if anything is negative right like
you're 65 years old and your website
expert right they'd look to the young
people so that's where you have an
advantage now it's never been easier to
get business as a young person if you're
in those certain fields where they
expect some credibility it was a little
harder for me I'm what I'm 36 36 what
year is it ya I'm 36 now I was 19 when I
was telling that stuff yeah so it was a
little bit harder but still all they
cared about was that I could help them
if I could add value to their lab then
they would want to talk to me and
potentially buy my software but I had to
get out of my own head and once i
realized that i could add guy like
believe that i could help them that I'm
not just trying to land a sale and take
their money but I believe that if they
bought what I had it would improve their
their lab that was the biggest ship much
more than what I said on the phone how I
introduced myself or any of that stuff
like made minor tweaks along the way but
the baby [ __ ] was me just feeling like I
will help you and that gives you
confidence and that lets you talk to
people who have more experience in you
and even when i first started work with
brands you know my first to brand
clients were xerox was xerox tell us
here in canada and in microsoft and i
thought these guys are huge companies
like what do they might ought to me for
right how am I gonna help Microsoft with
you know what is their budget for
marketing and I'm going to come in and
help Microsoft and so I put it off like
I didn't want to have that first call
because I felt like I couldn't
contribute and was better to delay it
than to be rejected and then when I
finally got on the call with them I
realized oh man I could totally help
Microsoft like these guys don't know
what they're doing or whoever it was
like they desperately need
they weren't tapped into the
entrepreneur community like I was and so
I realized that I had a lot of value to
give them and so now when i talk to
brands like go away knowing that i'm
confident i can help any brand that
wants to target entrepreneurs if you
want to sell makeup or something else I
can't help you you know but you want to
sell to entrepreneurs you want to stand
them I feel like I'm one of the best
people in the world to work with and so
I walk in with maybe maybe a little bit
of ego but more the confidence knowing
that I can help these guys and so you
need to have the build up the confidence
to know that hey I can help like that's
where the sales start to come in right
now you're not even in selling mode
you're just in research mode you're just
asking to set up meetings to understand
how people businesses work and people
give you the time right like why are we
talking now right you reach that ready
and said hey I like some help for my
business and I said sure let's do a
hangout and talk about it you know I'm
not getting paid for this now as far as
I know uh but so like that's it's
different because if you go up and say
hey I want to talk about my new product
or whatever they put them in defensive
mode because they're now expected to be
sold to where you're not you're not
selling you don't me miss Elliot you're
still trying to figure it out so the
only young entrepreneur who is
passionate about food waste and I'd love
to talk to you about your like the same
the same energy and enthusiasm that you
came up to me and talk to me it's tied
up Toronto for you know three minutes
after an event you could do that with
people who you wanted to get to know in
your industry and and they would spend
half an hour with you over coffee
talking about the business and you can
see where you might find it may not be
the excess food or may not be the same
model that you're thinking you may pivot
three or four times but the best way to
do it is around a customer and if they
like your energy and enthusiasm they
could say hey you know what if you could
solve this problem for me I'll pay you
for it right right like you're selling
without selling but I said going in with
the expectation of it not being a sales
call it's fact-finding that's that's
definitely sort of what I've been trying
to do a lot of sort of like food waste
campaigns a lot of sort of regional
managers at some of the grocery stores
and stuff I'm trying to reach out to
them and saying
hey this this this and I've been working
on something on a small scale I just
love to get your opinion and I things of
that nature and thankful I'm actually
one of them got back to me and with nice
little meeting next week and they just
loved our little story they were like
yeah we'd love to feature you guys and
be a part of the team so I definitely
that's that's really been a huge point
because instead of just selling my
product or idea uh selling them on
myself and what I thought about it
someone in the comments is saying óleo
is a food app that shares food waste so
maybe worth checking them out oh hi yeah
yeah they're known of the u.s. yeah I i
checked i believe i checked them check
one of them out cool i do a render the
galaxy for that I think you've got a lot
of stuff going for you that you're young
and that you're a student it's easy to
say yes to a student it's a lot harder
to say yes to hey I'm a 55 year old
person who's like trying to figure out
you know my next business idea right
yeah so it helps that you're younger
there but what I would add to it just
because you have a lot going for you
doesn't mean it can't be better what I
would add to it is when you're
introducing yourself tell me what you're
passionate about so high i'm sorry if
i'm a student at wherever your student
ID Lori Lori day I'm studying this I
have a passion for food waste or
whatever right um because if I can align
with the passion that you have then I'm
much more likely to say yes thank you
say I have a passion for for
entrepreneurship immediately like it
hits a soft spot for me right mm-hmm I
love entrepreneurs you want to be an
entrepreneur you know it makes me want
to help immediately I am that you're
young and your student and you know
you're you have energy and you want to
you know you open the ticking feedback
but that may help swing the curve a
little bit for people who are on the
fence as to whether they should meet you
or not just seeing what you're
passionate about and if they see that
and they say always passionate about
food waste like who cares that's why not
a great meeting for you anyway yeah
right so now people may be meeting you
because
you're you're young in a student but if
you throw that extra bit in about what
you're passionate about maybe do more
work about finding it and whatever it's
awesome or if you have a couple things
and you're still trying to figure out
like just sharing some of those things
if it pings on them something that they
can relate to they're much more likely
to say yes and if it pings on them in a
way that is negative then it's great
because it wouldn't have been a great
meeting for you anyway okay um I guess
my last last question I had was since
I'm working on a two-sided platform so
it's a chicken and egg type of situation
so can't have consumers without the
without the food providers like
restaurants bakeries you can't have one
or the other I mean I'm trying to focus
my efforts into gaining those bakeries
restaurants sushi places etc could you
speak a little bit about that like how
because I feel like you need to grow
both at the same time yeah you do yeah
so the easiest way to do it is you build
both up slowly so like if it were me I
would target a geographic area and in an
industry so if like sushi restaurants
downtown the comedy sushi restaurants
are there in downtown Toronto 40 like
50-100 I like a hundred okay so like
that's where I would focus go after the
hundred sushi restaurants in downtown
once you get one on board nobody wants
to be left out right like this guy's on
board matzo sushi whatever they're on
board and this guy's on boy like oh I
need to get on board too right I don't
want to be the only sushi place not on
your list even if this does nothing it
adds that feel to it and then I'd be
trying to target okay who are young
people downtown who care about sushi
like who's my demographic probably like
students student again like a
budget-conscious so how can I get
students who care about sushi so makes
it a lot easier and because of the
defining each of their high value client
so I'd be looking at okay well if you're
doing trials like University of
Toronto's downtown where I've seen
downtown how can i connect with those
guys there's meetup groups right and
let them know about these sushi deals
that they can get I go for the
restaurants first if I got 10
restaurants I start putting it up and
they've got that ability both yeah well
as soon as we have around some
consistent deals on a couple of
restaurants on board everything's gonna
go alive and what I'm planning on doing
is using some leverage leveraging some
of the free mediums like vice Huffington
Post's things of that nature where I can
just submit free articles and get a
little bit exposure in that sense but
also reaching out to the student base at
Ryerson UFT so I've been trying to talk
to some of the school newspapers exactly
if you'll get much more leverage from
local stuff than from a HuffPo article
mmm that helps with your SEO and that
kind of stuff your general awareness but
that's talking much more like national
international campaign where you can
just get a lot from your student from
the student base like I tried to get in
with u of t and Ryerson George Brown
maybe um and get them to know about it
and spread it and share it meetup groups
anything like hyperlocal that's where
you want to be so it's a smaller number
of people but those are your like people
aren't going to drive in from London
Ontario right to get a sushi deal you
know within an hour right like it's not
not going to happen yeah so I'll be
trying to make those local partnerships
um yeah uh I guess I'll squeeze in one
last question um if if you're working at
so just this is more like
entrepreneurial general type of question
if you're working on a business and you
see that opportunity and you're working
on it can you still develop a passion
for it later on as you work through it
or just always have to be that I'm
100-percent passionate about this and
that's why I did this I don't know that
you're always a hundred percent I think
I think your passion evolves I I would
be skeptical getting into a business and
then hoping that I will fall in love
with it I'd much rather start the other
way much rather start with something
that I love and try to figure out a way
to make it
something like if I were you before even
going out and start talking to those
restaurants I would do the self exercise
if you're going to what is it that I
want to do what do I get excited
passionate but because if this isn't it
this is you some opportunity then it's
better to figure that out now than two
years in and you're like not making
money and still like anything's going to
be a grind it's going to be a hustle
your face off thing and you're going to
doubt yourself and you're going to
critique yourself because take a while
to get going you're going to go through
hell to get there and the only thing
that gets you through is the passion
like this must happen I'm going to will
it into existence because it's important
so you have to feel that way about
something and can you develop it maybe
but it's like what I want to marry a
girl and then hope I fall in love with
her can it happen sure it can happen are
the odds good I don't know probably not
fantastic so I would approach it the
same way like how if I'm going to start
a business I would want to try to find
something that I'm passionate about and
go that way instead of try to find an
opportunity and then figure out how I'm
passionate about it okay perfect yeah I
think that might be some harsh truth but
ok I understand it's i mean that's
that's what I'm talking to you to
understand like what's going on what I
need to do cool cool well good luck
everybody is going to cheering you on in
the chat too so keep me posted ya think
thanks for taking the time um I was
actually going to send Sandra top ten
tips from what I learned from here so
i'll send you nice little message you
later on alright cool looking forward to
it alright awesome thank you thanks I
thank you guys thank you guys for
watching continue to believe and we'll
see you soon